in all of your classes growing up was
there one instructor that said something
to you that really changed your way of
thinking about writing and do you
remember that moment and what it was
that it where it really popped it made
sense could be something very basic can
be something more elaborate mmm
whether you were sitting in class
whether it was notes they gave you one
of the things about being at the MFA
program in playwriting this was so it
was still fairly fairly early on for me
at UCLA they as all universities they're
very big on employing inviting even in
as lecturers and you know it's part-time
people people known and it greatly
experienced in the industries and they
would come in and teach a course for
instance a graduate course there was a
world famous playwright in particular
who who came in and did this course a
wonderful wonderful man and a major
talent and I took the course and it
wasn't it wasn't the ultimate word of
wisdom that's not what I took away what
I took away from that course is every
writer and every life is different and
in a way sometimes that we do not even
want to hear it is truly up to us
writers have in their core hopefully the
ability we've you know we've been alone
all our lives and our thoughts to stand
alone because hearing about other
people's journeys in a personal way
these these people just weren't I mean
this particular individual too was a
wonderful soul but basically what he did
is he told old war stories for all
semester long and what we were writing
we wrote on our own we were it was up to
us in the entire time as a matter of
fact
UCLA nobody made any serious attempt to
teach me us the toolkit or approach or
structure of writing full-length plays
it was all touchy-feely and all up to
you and for a while there I was a bit
upset about that a bit ticked about that
it what did cost money and all that
stuff but yes I learned I learned what
they didn't it perhaps intend to teach
which is one person's journey is going
to be different from yours now this is
kind of the opposite of what you are
asking for you know this ultimate gem or
jewel of wisdom but I think it is a
jewel of wisdom that these are good
brilliant
accomplished artists who are most
sincere and their ability to share what
how they've done it and what they did be
able to share that with these
up-and-coming writers before them in the
grant program but I came away feeling
they didn't have a whole lot to share
and that's okay okay I get that we will
make our own path do you think because
they were so busy doing that they had a
hard time articulating how they did it
or no I don't know I think most of them
were instinctive writers they didn't
codify it and that's why when I came to
teach later came to teach screenplay I
was kind of obsessed with this has to be
you know this is teachable these are
smart people they can learn if we can
make this teachable it can be taught I
mean there are certain levels at which
skill talent it helps to have talent but
we all know I I certainly think I hope
most people understand that it's not
necessarily the most talented writers
who end up you know getting their
scripts sold and and
even made that's not how it works they
had they they come up with ideas for
stories
Hollywood buys stories not particulars
crypts by particular writer z-- and
their stories that take people on a
specific emotional journey knowing that
most likely they're going to come out
feeling good at the end yes yeah yeah
less less so with feeling good at the
end now today then once upon a time
have you seen life like we just saw that
recently have you seen life yet speaking
of a negative ending yeah but there's
still the gems but I get it I felt like
after maybe 9/11 things change but then
that's a whole nother topic but no yeah
good point
you